it's a World Series game on tonight you
like baseball
just because Nationals didn't make it
well I like Frank Robinson behind even
making the World Series mic testing
that's for that yeah team
yeah
testin testin
testin testin testin testin testin
testin test test i'm room for that I'm
moon for Chicago you know brothers on
the Astros now one there's some brothers
on the walls oh so we have any question
intelligent questions with audience
please also not not seriously no we're
not having auditions tonight I'm not
accepting manuscripts poems screenplays
not tonight
good I was happy for Alec yes
well have you see it says as told to so
clean after business really bright you
know Pakistani cattle is in London and
the last three or four years every time
I went there he asked me that the best
questions
he also he's also very good writer so
when he proce we're not doing a book I
said you should do a book about I told
him that the twin that adversity of
40-acre mules is coming up and so she
drew something and docked him in the
first you know the first twenty years
and so that's that's how that came about
yes a vice for screenwriting I would say
is to write write every day and even
those who want to write screenplays not
written the screenplay I would say start
a journal I think that before you want
to start writing screenplays you should
read screenplays and know what a
screenplay is and the format and all
that stuff yes
well that's the age-old question how you
get a if you don't have an agent how do
you get a screenplay scene well you
could direct yourself you can get it to
an actor I mean you just have there's
there's no one way to do anything you
just got to get out there and grind as I
say yes sir now the entertainment world
recognizes the singers to our writers is
where the actors were spotted by an
artist we get no representation itself
on like I'm sitcoms you might see a
painting on wall there are no boys
recognizing the work that out like a
Jacob Lawrence a town feeling how do you
feel about that how do you feel about
the fine artists is being recognized by
the public at large
well I buy it I'd buy the art first of
all let me just hang into my house and
so my man
this is we're not do not doing that
tonight baby yes Congressional Black
Caucus foundation had a panel last month
during their annual conference dealing
with screen politics film and television
and indicating that the rules have
changed what are your thoughts on the
rules of getting film motion picture as
well as television project cable
broadcast made for people of color or
just inspiring what rules are talking
about now know what the rules of change
is still you know still going out there
and doing you have to do to get the
project made there more avenues now I
think that before when I was in film
school the big thing was assets access
to equipment but with all these digital
cameras I mean excuse me can we shop
bamboozle it was a regular consumer
camera so I don't think if you have a
great idea I don't think you say I I
don't have the money you know the people
people find a way you know if you really
want to get a film made you want to get
a book published whatever you're gonna
find a way and are you gonna make away
yes sir
my question is is they still has a
segment called Roman Rome is rapid
Easter because in 2005 is still depicted
Eastern and white create Patrick
separate I will know if you see what do
you think about that I wanna see if I
saw Elizabeth Taylor's Cleopatra time
like him back then so you know you know
you know it's the same old same old you
know I was kid I was you know Martin
Scorsese a friend of mine and so you
know when they were doing Last
Temptation of Christ I say yo Marty
what's up with that but you know you
know they look like mr. Dafoe yes
million Moors March this year and I was
wondering the lack of voices such as mr.
Parsons from AOL time water or Kenaston
all from the American Express run then
why do you think that can tional
American Express and richard Parsons
chairman a Time Warner gonna show up as
something is sponsored or has the face
of fire come on the face if it's not
gonna happen so why even thinking like
that
come on yes do the right thing
did you know a lot of those characters
knew some some we made up I mean artists
you know draw upon their their life so
it's people that I've I think I was home
I was 20 25 when I wrote it so I mean it
was I had lived quarter of a century
that draw upon some experiences yes sir
on do you think we would see the
creation of a cable network different
from B et and TV one your similar to
Turner Classic Movies then we'll feature
Gurley black cinema like soundies
silence race films that's anything they
show a PBS tape documentaries other
further programming of the black
experience I think we've all seen B G
and T V one and not really educating our
folks as well or two we still are
portrayed negatively
who's gonna fund this that's my second
question I haven't gotten that yet just
brainstorming that's a good idea
you know exactly yes yes sir movies on
DVD I've been kind of frustrated as I've
been able to find she's got a have on
the 20th anniversary DVD yes sir plans
to do back to baseball i think plans to
do any work without Hank Aaron something
about his life is struggle I think
that's Barry Bonds and all that going on
no the next film we're talking about
about Joe Lewis asking me the next one
and hopefully we'll get Terrence Howard
to play Joe Lewis yes in your estimation
what what would you say is your smartest
investment and how would you say that
fit into my biggest deposit the question
was was my smartest investment
what kind of you took him out house I'm
boy that's two separate things
yes no I mean but uh for me as he was in
8 & 9 in my film so I mean look at
that's the legacy as far as I'm
concerned he knows the coach in school
days the mayor and do the right thing
the good Reverend doctor in jungle fever
I forgot his name and get on the bus
Jeremiah get on the bus what else the
eulogy and Malcolm X who's also in four
little girls so
I mean I was very fortunate to work and
also let's include Ruby Dee then with
that too yes we shot a film this summer
called Inside Man is coming out March
starring Denzel Washington Jodie Foster
Clive Owen William Dafoe it's about a
bank robbery - turns into a hostage
situation and then sir Washington plays
in New York City detective who has to
master match wits with the masked mind
the mastermind behind the robbery it was
played by Clive Owen so I'll be out in
March
and uh the fax number seven one eight
people slow I feel sorry you gotta
borrow pen to my people seven one eight
six two four two zero zero eight yes the
question is to have an advice to
aspiring young directors I would say
with your summer job flipping burgers
wherever you can be working by a camera
by a digital camera and just start
shooting doesn't have to be a movie just
just get accustom of the camera in your
hands and start shooting yes sir I
became a parent while we were doing for
little girls and so that affected me
deeply because the see the late alpha
Robison whose daughter Carol Robinson
was murdered or to talk to mrs. max met
mrs. Maxine McNair Chris McNair whose
daughter Denise McNair was murdered and
see how these parents were dealing with
their loss and then I mean anything how
how would I react or what would I do
with something like that had happened
too much I got well I got a lot of
strength from those parents and I in his
and speaking to a lot of the friends and
family in Burma Alabama seemed like we
were a different stock back then as a
people and so you know it had a great
influence you know on
you know I'm full of full of an example
because I in doing in doing the research
for the film we can't we found the
post-mortem photographs all the four
girls and I had to deliberate pray long
and hard about should we include these
photographs are horrible and I thought
that if I was a parent that I want them
to be seen - I thought it's important
that that Orient's whoever saw the film
see what these hundred sticks of
Dynamite's did these four young black
girls what the next the next thing at
the workout dough is will she be the
length of the shots because keep him on
too long would have been in bad taste so
we had to work on it and all the parents
and relatives approved when I saw the
film that they also thought that those
photographs should be included in the
film and I and if anyone hasn't seen
full of girls I hope you do get it it's
on DVD gotta wear it look hard for it
but it's one of the best things I've
done I think yes yes
theory said that's not going to be the
only story look at so there are thousand
stories in to probably tells you have
but that's what documentary filmmakers
do you have to choose what story and you
aren't to tell so you know we won't you
will do that yes Oscar Michele's film
was in the gates and I was just
wondering for you talk a little bit
about your life the relationship between
that birth nation and your student film
the answer is not available it'll never
be available the answer is my first
student film in New York University grad
at Film School and I saw like a response
to birth of a nation DW Griffith film
which is considered by a lot of film
scholars the greatest film ever made
indeed the difference also cited as the
father cinema and when winning the film
school I mean we were you know beat
overhead with that stuff and you know we
would question our teachers because they
leave out the fact that this film was
used as a recruitment tool for the Klan
that thousands of black men got
castrated and whipped hung whatever
because of that film but they will
always leave that part out so this film
saw like an answer or 20 minute answer
to that film yes filmmakers once you get
the tools
I thought they were
why don't you tell everybody at court
and into the mic so they could hear you
I was saying tying in with the question
this man asked over here for aspiring
filmmakers once you get the tools like
where do you go from there
well once you get the tools you have to
make a film and then you go to the film
festival as you said in the film out you
just try to get your work scene but I
said before there's no one way to do
anything so you had to find out which
path is the best for you yes
while think about that real I just I'm
just trying to tell a story so do the
right thing is about the hottest day of
the summer I mean that had the title
first and I said the second thing I
thought of it it's gonna be it's gonna
take place in the hottest day of the
summer and everything else came after
that yes I'm tired of being sued and
people sue the drop of a hat you know I
have enough stuff that hat I work on
myself so right now I'm just focusing on
doing when I'm writing and what I think
our Democratic National Party I just
think that they have to get it in attack
mode you know against Reagan oops
Reagan Bush Bush you're all the same
and you know you know but I think that
enough is going wrong with the
Republican Party right now with I mean
always hit all the guys his boys didn't
hot water now you know we're approaching
the 2000 dead mark and Iraq looks like
there's no way out
so I mean does it doesn't look it
doesn't look good despite what mrs. rice
says with their ferragamo shoes
yes part of your book and I've noticed
that a lot of which do a lot of black
artists got so their start or at least
more recognition through your films and
I was just wondering the relationship
you sort of have a ongoing positive
relationship and you get feedback right
hey Thank You spike for giving me this
chance or right now but we don't that's
not the reason why we do we're trying to
get the best people for the movie you
know it's not like so well you know some
people you have relations with some
people you don't you know I've been in
four films with Denzel we don't hang out
together but you know we love working
with each other so it is just you know a
school like that
yes I was wondering if you could share
anything about your personal philosophy
your way of approaching problems you're
looking at things that
the question is how do I overcome
obstacles well I think that when you
think that this obstacle in your way I
think that we draw upon history and
think about the obstacles on ancestors
had it doesn't add up what hands test
has had and what we have and so I think
that we all draw strength from that
knowing that ass has went through holy
hell so we could be in a position that
where they were live today and see the
stuff we're dealing with they would say
autumn and ice has left some light stuff
that's some light stuff so I always
think about my ancestors what do you
know why getting a tough spot and I
start you know you know getting a little
down set now you know and then I just
elevates me back up yes sir that you
would love to work I like to work with
Jamie Foxx I like to work with Terrence
Howard I don't like to work with Sean
Penn we gotta leave that shotgun home
I still have pictures short in New
Orleans that's it what's he doing it's
not good so I got I got asked about that
next time I see you I say who are you
gonna shoot
I had thing about them yes don't like it
yes don't have a favourites but we had a
lot of fun on school days
looks like it right and a lot of fun to
do the right thing to bond upon summer
sin yes the 15th amendment and how we
they have to keep extending the
prerequisite act for the protection of
blacks and minorities to keep the right
to vote well for me that stuff doesn't
really faze me because I just go back to
Constitution United States America where
it said we did three-fifths of human
beings so if it's an if it's in the
Constitution United States something
that this whole country is built upon
hope the foundation the country is the
Constitution United States of America
and in that document it says we're
three-fifths of human being does not
tell you something
there you go
yes with the book yes
I have for me the only press acquit I
have you know directness something that
I didn't write as if it's good or not
you know what what I like I really can't
tell you give you a laundry list of what
it is I like but I'd note when I read it
yes sir lover thank you will represent
room
I came to knowledge didn't get on the
bus was initially finance curly black
investment dollars and then in the end
was the soul that was completely made
and that had never been done before in
montage and knowing that you haven't
done before but that what you described
was true okay
I'm just wondering with with all the
wealth that some black people will have
in this country why is it that that
rarity in your opinion why you're still
talking about Hollywood why is it that
we don't have that ability to fund the
government and do some films and see it
some fruition as the success well they
are there are films made outside of
Hollywood that are independent films you
know I know because people send me that
you know try to do hand me the DVDs on
on the street but but I think that we
have to really make a clear distinction
because there are black people who have
a lot of money but I don't think we have
to get past a point expecting black
entertainers to raise the money for
distribution or for films there's enough
black people who are the NBA's who are
venture capitalists who had those skill
sets that's required the same way you
don't think someone who was with MBA
you'll add a skill sets to direct the
movie and it really depends on the
budget
get on the bus cost 3.5 million dollars
now will you try to raise 10 million
dollars I don't think we'd have made
that film but we were able to do with
three and a half so you know I don't
think Nancy question I don't think we're
there yet as a people and also film was
a risky investment to master something
that should never be left out film is a
very risky investment and the joy two
films lose money
how many years a picture is shown in to
do movies that were junk that would put
in a lot of money so who was put in a
certain number theaters Amistad was put
in a certain number theater and they
made made money so who became a
television series but it was not put in
half the theaters that are what's that
guy that made uh what is there Quiet
Storm oil but whatever that movie was
about the guys in the boat in the water
George Bush George clearly like I don't
know what and his movie still didn't he
had a movie out that unit still didn't
make half the money so who me but it was
put in three times two theaters so I we
come as many white moviegoers in America
than black that's true but listen list o
screen yes someone determines that but
every movie that's released if you you
look at the theaters in this country
there's many different you know every
city is not like chocolate city there
Parsons country there no black people
they're not gonna take they're not gonna
put soul food in 100 theaters in Salt
Lake Utah
with the cost of prints and the cost the
advertisement also there's not a surplus
the theaters so they look at the
demographic everything is different
graphics black domes come out there's 25
top african-american markets that's the
ones they go to first now there's some
white people in the film then they'll
spread out more that's the way it works
that is the way they figure out how many
screens they're not gonna make 5,000
copies of soul food and put in every
single theater the United States of
America it doesn't work like that yes
when they sign a contract it's their job
what was your attire sir no no no no no
no no but what was your time where do
you work at let me can I just suggest
you wear something to work tomorrow I
want you wear a Jim Brown throwback
Cleveland Browns Jersey some Rocawear
jeans to hang and blow your but I'm
gonna braid your hair up we'll put some
extensions on it so I'll be a little
longer I'm gonna get you some caps for
your teeth and I want where you work in
federal government your Census Bureau oh
yeah you work you fit right in and tell
me if you have a job by the end of the
week you know David Stern's acting like
the overseer and they're cracking down
but you know what if everything turned
with the fight in Detroit you know it's
like and this is really about money and
when they make corresponds to the saying
this gangster stuff is not making it you
know they got a total line
yes what's the term business casual they
got the guide the cats got suits they
got suits yes what were you trying to
make some sort statement or is that just
how it happened it's a shot I mean it's
it's a very distinct I mean gun does
just end up on a Bible by mistake and
the lady is a movie no yet the whole
relationship between Gator which is
played by Samuel Jackson and oz a day
was was really based upon you know
Marvin Gaye senior and Marvin Gaye
junior Margate senior was a minister and
so that's where he got that from
yes still there I'll quit if you know
when when I'll have that passion yes yes
my wife and I've written two children's
look the first is please baby please the
next one the next one is please puppy
please and we would joke and the third
one should be please [ __ ] please that
be at New York Times best self
it'd be like this so baby I don't know
where that slips it came from then we go
to refrain I'll be a seller couple more
yes in which I wrote comments and those
really making an impact such as
interview you mentioned Eddie Murphy who
was really riding high with this action
film at that time being able to empower
other people of color in all areas of
the of the filmmaking process from
caterers to floral designers obviously
to other technicians do you still feel
the same way and have you found there
been any changes in Hollywood of
empowering more people of color to get
those contracts well I mean it depends
Me Mine
I mean this is a long time ago but Eddie
Murphy and I have discussions like Eddie
after you do learn more and he would say
well it's paramount you know as their
company I said but you made you made two
billion dollars for them so you got to
say so it's just two different biologies
yes
I don't think you answered but I know
jungle fever you didn't comment on will
you be commenting or no jungle fever
when that DVD can't came out they
weren't even they weren't even doing
direct the commentary so this gonna be
oh yeah I did already
get on it who hasn't asked enough yes is
a combination I mean if there's a very
demanding role especially with the whole
lot of dialogue I'm not gonna give this
someone who's never been in front of the
camera before but there's a specific
part that that was written and that
person is that you know we've supposed
to comment this really depends you know
when you're doing the film you trying to
cast a film you're just trying to define
the best people for the part and I mean
Rosie Perez has never acted before do
the right thing but we felt that a
notice she could play that part no Tina
yes
give me Sucker Free City no I was not in
the back but the Yankee had yes we close
on a story ten years ago it was just it
just had become too much of a headache
we will continue to make I mean the film
we just finished this summer inside man
we shot a large part in the Brooklyn
Navy Yard which is a new studio
Hollywood studio it sounded book of
neighborhoods yes we will continue to
shoot in Brooklyn
we shot part of our get on the bus here
in DC and a couple shots to four she's
full she hate me yes podcasts are
amazing I mean people you know company
and said what made the thing with the
podcasts of it's a man funny was the guy
was doing it I'm on the set a phone a
cell phone has rung uh-oh there's a $50
fine the cell phone rings whose cell
phone is it I mean he was the guy he
just went over the top but it made an
enjoyable listening yes miss me last
question well it's really not a big
thing for me
if you look at it basically all my films
have taken place in New York City and
summer that summer 1977 was the first
summer we're actually started a shooting
stuff so I remember that summer very
very dearly and was a crazy summer